welcome to your new favorite Call of
Duty playlist war brought to you by Call
of Duty World War 2 war is an all-new
multiplayer game mode where players must
work as a team to defeat the enemy it's
an immersive narrative driven experience
that pits Allied and Axis forces against
each other in team driven assault and
defend missions set within iconic World
War 2 locations each match is divided
into two rounds with you alternating
roles between the Allies and axis your
mission changes depending on which side
you find yourself on typically with one
side acting as the aggressor and the
other side running defense as the
attackers you'll need to complete a
string of objectives against the clock
each requiring close cooperation and
adaptive tactics naturally it's the
defenders job to do everything in their
power to keep those objectives
unfulfilled and the clock ticking all
the way down to zero
war absorbs elements from a variety of
popular modes and amalgamates them into
something that feels completely new
within just one game you'll capture and
hold zones in similar fashion to
domination and hardpoint construct Sambi
style defensive walls and gun nests
indulge in some search and destroy bomb
defusal and even a score to payload in
scenes reminiscent of safeguard there
are also elements completely unique as a
war including some seriously hazardous
bridge building now let's get one thing
out of the way regardless of your skill
level you will die and there's every
chance that you'll die a lot this is a
mode that forces you to move beyond KD
ratios and score streaks because there's
far more important things at stake so
leave your lone wolf instincts at the
door and prepare to make some heroic
sacrifices for the good of the squad
which brings us to our first tip for
success communication obviously this is
a mode best suited for party play and
the ability to react and respond to
enemy tactics as a unit rests on your
ability to coordinate with the rest of
your team as each objective is focused
on a small chunk of a large map calling
out enemy positions and objective
locations in the heat of combat is much
more easily done than other modes if
chat is impossible pay close attention
to the in-game dialogue which reacts
intelligently to situations and observes
the roles of your teammates of playing
so that you can provide useful support
if somebody's taking the risk to perform
some construction be the one to lay down
covering fire so their efforts aren't in
vain or if a zone is being captured aim
to defend any potential flanking
positions war is also a great reason to
have a loadout slot dedicated to each
division a shotgun or SMG might be
perfectly suited for close quarters
engagements when capturing a building
but are near useless when you're
separated by a trench as with all other
modes matching the weapons your choice
of division means your gun will receive
a vital additional perk which can make
all the difference the same thinking
applies to your grenades never before
has a smoke grenade been such an
essential part of your loadout as it's
the perfect means of obfuscating and
objective and making it that much
harder for the opposition to get their
sights trained on you as you become
better acquainted with the various maps
you can start to have a loadout suited
to each objective and switch between
them when the occasion calls for it
although you will have to suffer a noble
death for the change to take effect
although you won't be earning any
scorestreaks you will receive additional
aid from air drops these acts just like
care packages in normal multiplayer
modes but the reward is fixed and
tailored to the map the major difference
here is that the perk remains in your
armory until the gas or ammo runs out so
if you're quick enough to nab that
flamethrower you'll keep it after you
respawn just don't fool yourself into
thinking that they'll make you
unstoppable finally if you ever find
yourself escorting a tank that armored
payload isn't just for show while the
tank movements is automated the gun
turret is up for grabs and grants you
awesome firepower for as long as you can
avoid being shot the obvious trade-off
is that you're completely out in the
open and a good six feet higher than
usual so your enemies will see you
coming a mile off watch your head
war is a mode that rewards players and
teams who work smart think on their
boots and exploit the environment to
their advantage most importantly though
it's fresh frantic and fun and will
force even the most battle-hardened Call
of Duty veteran to completely rethink
the way they play
[Music]
you